un joli manteau blanc a recouvert saint
quentin en yvelines vers 10 heures les
premiers flocons ont commencé à tomber
rapidement déneigement et salage ont eu
lieu ça se passe plutôt bien
on a été un peu surpris au départ mais
dans l'ensemble tout s'est bien passé ça
glisse par endroits mais bon ça c'est
normal
et donc voilà on fait refaire certaines
zones qui ont été qui ont été traitées
mais qui entre temps par manque de
brassage c'est-à-dire par manque de deux
passages de voitures ben voilà ça ça se
recouvrent et dont il faut refaire
passer les saleuses mais dans l'ensemble
tout et tout est bien dans l'après-midi
le rôle des patrouilleurs est de
vérifier les conditions climatiques afin
de savoir si d'autres passages sont
nécessaires mais les plus heureux ce
sont sûrement les enfants partout dans
les rues on voit luge traîneaux et après
ski ils sont tous sortis de chez eux
pour des raisons bien précises
et les enfants n'ont qu'un seul espoir
les douze déneigeuses ont été mobilisés
le temps de cet épisode la neige
elle s'est arrêtée de tomber vers 15h30